yeah so I'm like in true fashion I am
trying to get this live demo to work I
might have to just undo a bunch of stuff
and be happy with
hello hello is that better sweet
yeah I'll also just speak louder cool
awesome so as Kaz said my name is Niels
I work at arena which is a our analytics
company we mainly serve hospitals and
our main product offering is you know we
recommend job applicants for our clients
to hire so I mean with that premise you
can see why I'm kind of concerned about
this particular topic and so you know
what I'll be talking about today are a
few kind of high-level concepts trying
to define discrimination in the first
place and what fairness means and then
conceptualizing that in machine learning
and I'll be talking about a package that
I wrote a couple months ago that tries
to implement a few of these techniques
cool so what does bias have to do with
ice cream
just making sure this is the right slide
deck yeah okay sweet
well so did you know bias has many
meanings and in statistics it means a
particular thing and in a colloquial
sense it means also another thing so in
colloquial sense it's simply a
preference for or against something so
simply put you know I like ice cream you
like chocolate I like vanilla ice cream
you like chocolate ice cream and you
know we don't really have there there's
no like issue with that
like really unless someone can think of
something and the main kind of bias I
want to talk about today is algorithmic
bias which I define as a set of
mathematical rules that systematically
favors one group over another so
implicit in kind of my conversation and
my discussion here is is that bias is
kind of an aim a moral thing so it's you
know we don't really have any value
judgments about preferring vanilla over
ice cream but a type of bias that is
harmful I would say is algorithmic bias
in in this kind of flavor so this is an
example that was published by Pro
Publica I'm not sure if people here
who's seen this kind of image and read
that article so that it was a kind of a
great analysis and and an example of
kind of trying to reproduce or kind of
reconstruct a model and try to
understand a little bit better but
basically this is an example where I
think it was a kind of survival model
that tried to assess the risk of a
particular person going through
recidivism so these are prison inmates
and the bias that the model held was
that it would classify black people as
having a higher risk of recidivism when
they in fact did not what's what's the
proper were there but when they did not
go back to jail and it would favorably
say that white people had less risk when
in fact they did so just to be really
clear here I kind of want to put these
terms in front of you and kind of just
soak it in and I'll kind of go through
each and take a little bit of time here
so bias as I mentioned is a moral
concept so it's the preference for or
against something
whereas discrimination is a moral
concept in that it's an action
discrimination happens when an action is
based on biases that lead to the
systematic disenfranchisement of a
particular social group based on some
arbitrary characteristics
and on the flip side I kind of do have
this hand wavy definition of fairness as
the opposite or the lack of
discrimination and there's a whole
literature on on all of these three
topics and in social science and and the
legal literature but today I'll be
focusing my discussion mainly on this
concept of potential discrimination so
when when data and a model favorably
predicts you know so it was respected
with respect to some kind of target
variable like a prove alone a deny alone
or higher no higher discrimination in
the machine learning context is when a
particular social group experiences some
kind of harmful outcome like getting
their loans denied more often than other
social groups so this is a problem
because if you imagine a world in which
people make make biased decisions which
is I think the world we live in is just
kind of like a natural part of the world
then we're generating you know these
biased decision records so we're
generating biased data so imagine a bank
loan officer who is you know against
like doesn't like immigrants and will
just deny loans of immigrants and so
when you generate these bias data and
you don't really you're not really
critical about it you you you obtain
this data somehow and as a data
scientist you kind of you're happy to
get all these labels and all these
decision records see then you train an
algorithm on it that algorithm even
though the math and the instruction set
of like how you learn an algorithm that
I would say is objective so it's a set
of mathematical rules however I think
the thing that is missed in a lot of
these conversations is that there's a
difference between an algorithm or a
model and an instantiated model so an
instantiated model is a model that has
learned and seen some examples of your
data
and if that data has reflects those
biased decisions then it's gonna learn
those biases and by the way this also
happens even if you don't include any
kind of sensitive attribute like race
gender sex kind of underlying
correlations between other seemingly not
related or non sensitive features will
will will get you these bias kinds of
algorithms and then these algorithms
will generate predictions which then
feed back to into the real world
and you know you have this kind of
vicious square circle I don't know so so
it's just to reiterate the problem
machine learning models optimized only
for accuracy so some some notion of
accuracy like your model fit to your
data at hand reflecting at amplify
real-world social biases so instead of
thinking of an ml model as a black box I
think a mirror is a much more apt
metaphor and I would say black mirror is
a much more apt metaphor because like
the TV show there are all these
unintended consequences that can happen
when you kind of thoughtlessly or not
even thoughtlessly but you just kind of
take for granted that your labels are
true you know your ground truth which we
often say if the ground truth but I
think you know I think we need to push
on on that a little bit okay so my
proposed solution partial solution is a
package called Themis ml it's named
after the Greek Titan of Justice and
Themis was already taken so I had to add
there excuse me
so this is open source it's on github
right now it's on on it's kind of a
super alpha version so it's built on top
of SK learn so anyone who's familiar
with that API should be able to jump in
pretty quick
and train these kinds of D biased models
okay
so sorry jumping back so I kind of
defined this thing called a fairness
aware machine learning interface and
it's just kind of a fancy way of saying
does your machine learning API support
the notion of sensitive attributes and
some measure of fairness or
discrimination and not just you know
like accuracy or you know your typical
confusion matrix metrics and things like
that so a couple of things that I
thought about when designing this this
this package is these three things so
what I mean about what I mean by model
flexibility is that depending on the
user you might have full control over
your model training process in which
case you know you work it up a company
and you're using kind of lower-level
libraries and you actually have access
to you know the objective function and
your learning algorithm so so that's
great but if you're using kind of an
out-of-the-box solution then you might
want to have the ability to use
different models that don't really
depend on some of these fairness aware
techniques and I'll get into that a
little bit but model flexibility is
about different use cases
do I want to pre-process my data so that
you kind of scrub a little bit of the
correlations between your features and
your protected attributes so
again just to clarify the terminology
but protected class is like a legal
concept such as race religion gender
there I think 20 or so of these in the
US law ok the second point is thinking
about fairness as performance
so as an ml person I am very happy when
I get like a 99% accuracy on my you know
my test set and I think thinking about
fairness as a measure of performance is
like this is kind of vague in my own
mind at this point but I think ways of
including both accuracy and fairness in
in the training process and in modeling
in general I think is an important move
and then finally there's this thing
called the fairness utility trade-off
and so in some techniques it's very
noticeable and others it's it's less of
there's less of an association here but
mainly it's the idea that the fair your
algorithm is the less accurately it's
going to perform it's a basic idea
okay so what is an FMLA the way I like
to think of it is they're kind of these
two orthogonal concerns so one is
discrimination discovery so even before
you train a model you want to get a
sense then this is this is kind of where
traditional statistics blends in with
machine learning a little bit because
here you start caring about confidence
intervals you know whereas in machine
learning you're you do you still do but
it's it's less of an emphasis so the
objective of discrimination discovery is
given a set of decision records x and y
targets we want to define a measure of
social bias B with respect to this
protected class s and then identify a
subset of potentially discriminated
decision records so this cartoon at the
bottom just says you know their equal
number of men and women and this say
hiring pool there's some kind of unknown
decision process that determines who
gets hired or not and then in the end
you get more what men than women hired
into you know say software engineering
or something so so why is that so that
this is this this is what is at the core
of discrimination discovery is what what
are the the related features or what are
the like how some hypotheses about like
what's what's causing this or what
yeah what's causing this okay so I kind
of want to make a distinction here and
it's again this is kind of can be a
little bit gray in many cases but in in
the legal world there are these two
things called disparate treatment and
disparate impact and so this is a
cartoon that tries to illustrate this
concept where again we're looking at a
hiring decision process and disparate
treatment is an explicit it's kind of
like an explicit treatment of on the job
post it's like only men apply network
we're not going to look at women's
resumes and then you know obviously
somehow one woman got through and in
this case but you know so that that's
that's this is a situation in which it's
an explicit differential treatment
between you know social your kind of
sensitive attribute of interest in this
case
sex disparate impact on the other hand
is a little bit more insidious because
you're like yeah yeah well we get will
take everyone's resume you know well
there's nothing explicit about it but
there's something in between sending in
your resume and you know the recruiter
making a decision that leads to
differential outcomes and again this
this is it's really I want to emphasize
that this is really hard and people like
in economics and social science like try
to statistically not even with ml like
try to unpack these kinds of questions
and and they're not straightforward so
you know take all of this with a grain
of salt
cool so some more cartoons at the so
with respect to disparate impact one can
measure discrimination at the individual
level and at the group level so what I
mean by individual level is I'm gonna
pick two individuals the big circles and
I'm gonna look at like disregarding all
the this explicit kind of obvious
socially sensitive attributes I'm gonna
find you know the nearest neighbors
this particular individual so I'll
unpack this a little bit later but just
say we have a sense of distance between
these folks and these are the five
closest people you know to this this one
person same goes for this this one for
some reason I only put three but at the
individual level I'm gonna look at the
outcomes of this person relative to the
people around this person and so let's
say this is hiring again so these people
got hired and these people did not get
hired but with respect to this
individual all all the decisions are
consistent and the same goes here this
person was not hired and all the people
around her would were not hired so
that's that's one way of conceptualizing
some notion of consistency so how how
consistent is your decision process or
algorithm that's generating some
predictions at the group level it's this
is you know the idea of statistical
paradiso of of men and women what
proportion are hired and not hired and
so this gets a sense of like at the
group level you know this according to
one of the metrics I'll be showing in a
bit this will evaluate to 0 so 0.5 minus
0.5 whereas you know if you imagine one
of these men up here and one of these
women down here that's going to evaluate
to some positive number positive yeah I
think so
okay so that was the first dimension of
FML ice it's an API that enables you to
easily evaluate your data set you the
kind of heavy lifting that the user has
to do is you have to identify your
sensitive attributes and then your
target of interest cool
so the second dimension is fairness
aware machine learning so these are
techniques where you can train a model
that is relative to a fairness unaware
model will produce less biased
predictions so yeah I guess you can read
the task I mean pretty much the same as
discrimination discovery but that the
task is to learn an actual model
cool
so just some preliminary kind of
notation stuff like defining some terms
so these are like the two two key
assumptions that I'm gonna make in the
context of this presentation and also
this is these are the assumptions made
by CMS ml at this point so we're gonna
assume that we're only doing binary
classification tasks because it's easy
to reason about where y plus or one is a
beneficial outcome like good credit risk
and y minus equals zero is a is a bad
adverse outcome so you're labeled as bad
credit risk the second assumption is you
know they have these two values DNA
which is a member of the this set s that
is also a binary variable so we're not
again this is like the very simplest
kind of toy model kind of way of
thinking about this obviously there are
many races there are many kinds of you
know things are not binary even though
we like we like to kind of bucket bucket
things like that so D is equals one is
the disadvantage group so again here you
have to make an assumption about who the
disadvantaged group and it is in the
first place and then a is equal zero is
your advantage group so you know example
here is disadvantaged group is an
immigrant and advantage group is citizen
okay so we'll talk about like
discrimination discovery and my fairness
aware machine learning just anchored to
kind of a typical machine learning
pipeline so this is pretty generic you
have some raw data at the top you pre
process it you have some model
specifications that you train you then
you have your instantiated models that
you evaluate you deploy it and you make
predictions on your data
you have it where you have it in
production and it's at surfing you know
its purpose how my own time cool alright
so the first sensible thing to do before
even trying to train them fairness aware
model is you want to evaluate you want
you want to measure the degree of
discriminate discriminatory patterns or
technically potentially discriminatory
patterns in your data so one way of
doing that is mean difference and this
for statisticians in the room looks very
familiar or it should should feel feel
quite familiar you're just measuring the
proportion of advantaged folks who
experience the beneficial outcome and
you subtract from that the proportion of
disadvantaged folks in your data set the
experience the beneficial outcome so
values range from negative one to one
where one is the maximum discrimination
discrimination case so like all men are
hired and all women are not hired zero
is it's a statistical parity case and
negative one is I mean I don't know how
people feel about the term reverse
discrimination but it just means like
you had your assumptions wrong so you're
you're it's like if all citizen all
immigrants got their bank loans accepted
and then all citizens got their bank
loans denied so that Larry are like okay
so who's advantaged in this case
cool so another cartoon just to make it
super explicit this is what I showed you
sort of before so zeros this is a
statistical parody case and then any any
positive number means that the
advantaged group experiences the the
beneficial outcome more often
cool the second example that I want to
show about you know evaluating the
discriminatory discriminatory patterns
in your data is this this notion of
consistency I won't read these
instructions I think maybe the slides
will be put online at some point so this
is just like a good reference but
another cartoon so this is how you would
calculate consistency so I like thinking
in extremes because it kind of clarifies
what's in the middle to me at least so
you know the extreme case of a
completely consistent decision process
you're going to get a number one and a
completely inconsistent so so let's look
at here so the purple folks are
homeowners and then the orange folks are
not homeowners and this is supposed to
be you know your true predictor of
whether you should have a loan or not
and you have these folks and kind of
business formal outfits but basically
you look at this particular homeowner
and you pick the five nearest neighbors
so other homeowners and you see you know
her loan was denied but everyone else's
was accepted you know regardless of you
know the sex of these nope neighbors
same goes here all the neighbors got
rejected whereas this one was accepted
so it's a by this metric inconsistent
decision process
there's some there's actually something
similar called situation testing it's
kind of where you take a resume and you
it's kind of like an a/b test for racism
where you you have one resume have like
a black sounding name one another resume
of so that this is kind of a similar
type of test like kind of in concept
cool so you know say there are
discriminatory patterns in your data so
so what can you do about it there are
three kind of entry points for you know
the Themis ml API where you can
pre-process your change the way your
pre-processing your data I'll mention
all caveats after I've described these
technic techniques but the first one is
relabeling and again I'll just show you
the cartoon instead of reading it out
but this is this is kind of to give an
intuition so on the x-axis you have is
homeowner like before no on the y-axis
you have income the Diamonds are women
and the circles are men green is good
credit risk red as a bad credit risk so
you know you take these labels again as
ground truth you're like okay these are
this is the way the world should be and
then you learn a decision boundary some
model you know maybe the decision
boundary should really should be here
but for the purposes of this I just drew
here
that's your model trained on the
original data with relabeling your your
make a very strong assumption which may
or may not be true so you use your gonna
assume that the labels are incorrect and
we should directly change them in favor
of the disadvantaged group and the way
this assumption works out is is you look
at the decision boundary and you look at
some and a number of points closest to
it and then the way you translate this
into this assumption into English is
like this woman
God assigned bad credit risk because she
was a woman and so I'm gonna go in I'm
gonna change the data set directly same
goes for the man here so you're gonna
you're gonna promote the woman promote
this is all jargon and then you're gonna
demote the man and then you're gonna
learn a new boundary so this is in
essence kind of extreme version of this
like in 2d how this technique would work
so the benefit of this is you can do
this once and then you can train any
arbitrary model on these data there are
risks though the second one is so with
relabeling you're changing the bra data
and post-processing you are at the
prediction layer you're taking a model
that had no notion of fairness or
discrimination and you're gonna change
the prediction so very similar in
concept to relabeling so what this is
going to do is you're not going to mess
with the model or the raw training data
you're just going to say we'll have some
kind of preset you know parameter that
says you know how close an observation
should be to the decision boundary and
you're just going to flip the
predictions and that in syria should get
you like their predictions
yeah so the strong assumption here is is
is similar to okay so before I get into
the training the main reason I I think
the more robust sort of methods are in
this category as opposed to relabeling
or like the pre-processing and
post-processing is that with the former
- you're kind of it I don't know it
field doesn't feel very satisfying to me
you're kind of you have to make very
strong assumptions about your data and
you know if those assumptions are
justified I think you know go go ahead
and do it but as I'll describe here I
think theoretically these these training
methods are a lot more satisfying so
with the additive counterfactually fair
model or ACF what you're doing is this
you have your features your non
sensitive features X and then you have
your protected classes s what you're
doing is you're training and this is in
the linear context so it just whenever
you see the word model just zoom that's
linear so you're going to train a
residual model that's gonna use your
protected class s as input and it's
going to try to predict your features X
each feature and then it's going to
output some prediction of what those
features X should be in theory what this
is doing is this is this model is
capturing the correlation between your
protected classes s and X so it's like
what you know if this is a logistic
regression model it's like what weight
do I put race like how much should I
wait race when determining zip code like
probably a lot how much should I wait
race when determining his homeowner home
on
probably a lot as well but I so you got
the idea you get get some kind of
reconstruction of your initial features
X and you do this operation you say
scrub my initial features off of these
correlations like remove these
correlations from my original features
and you get you know this capital
epsilon or e these are what people call
residual features that are in theory
scrubbed of the correlations between
your inputs and your sensitive feature
then you train this through like a any
arbitrary model and you got your
prediction so this entire system is the
additive counterfactually fair model the
interesting thing about this that I want
to note is that you can use any
arbitrary number of protected classes so
you're not limited to just one which is
an interesting thing cool and then the
name of this one is pretty I was like my
favorite like prejudice remover
regularization so this one like who here
knows about regularization or has heard
the term cool well if you do know about
it then
for those who don't sorry it's basically
a technique where in typical you know
linear systems or nonlinear systems you
are gonna try to have the model not rely
on one single feature so if your model
is waiting one feature like has cat by a
lot than the regularization term and
your objective function is going to kind
of tamp that down so your model doesn't
rely on any one feature and hence
reduces overfitting to your training
data so credit prejudice remover
regularization is something that
introduces another regularization term
to your objective function and this is
the most math I think I'll have
and I'm not going to go through
everything in detail but that's why I
put some colors in boxes so just look at
the colors in boxes so basically the
blue thing is your typical you know say
l2 regularization and what that's saying
is don't wait a particular feature too
much and this thing in red this is your
this is the logistic regression case so
what this is saying is don't make
mistakes on predictions with respect to
the true labels so this thing is gonna
be this term is gonna be large if it
gets predictions wrong and finally you
have this prejudice index regularization
term and this equation actually is
otherwise known as mutual information in
information theory but basically what is
this is saying so if you just
concentrate on these two this quotient
you're saying what is my prediction
given a particular protect protected
protected class over you know your
prediction predictions in general so
this should be one if if your prediction
and the socially sensitive attribute are
conditionally independent so this is
saying don't depend on sensitive
features too much to make predictions so
it's similar in concept to l2 but here
you're explicitly encoding you know a
sense of
you're explicitly encoding your
sensitive features into your objective
function so this is what I meant when I
said this is the most satisfying because
you're basically you're introducing a
term in the actual learning algorithm
that will then give you a model that
doesn't rely on race as much or you know
picky picky are protected attributable
choice so this is I try to like think of
a cartoon to represent this idea as best
as I could
and this is what I could come up with so
in the red is your fairness unaware
objective function that's the thing
without this yellow box so think of
machine learning is just skiing down a
slope and you're as you're skiing you're
skiing you're like finding the gradient
of your cost function and you're trying
to find the point in the space with the
lowest cost so that's nice and read what
the fairness aware model the this
prejudice remover regularization is
doing is this kind of changing the shape
of your function so let's just say the
shape of your function changes to this
and now your lowest point is here and so
now you've picked sorry I need to step
back x-axis is the value of your weight
of your features and y-axis is cost
function and so what what this is saying
is that this is an actual like if you
hold your true labels to be true and
like non-problematic and everything is
good and happy this is the point you
should pick and this is you know the
model parameter setting that you should
pick but then you're introducing this
new saying in blue and you're like okay
actually if I care about not being
racist like this is this is where I
should be in space and if you evaluate
the cost at this setting of your
original you know your original
objective function you get a cost here
so this is kind of an instance of the
fairness utility trade-off
we're in that you have you know your
training set in your true labels and
really to get the most accuracy or
utility out of your model you're gonna
pick this one but since you now you're
carrying a little bit you know or a lot
about fairness in the particular sense
that it's encoded in the prejudice index
then you're gonna get a slightly worse
performance by the way this term this
ADA term
is literally like how much you care
about fairness so if it's zero then that
term drops off and then anything greater
than that you're like starting to care
about you know how biased your
predictions are okay I think I might
have time
so next I'm gonna look at this data set
called the German credit data set it's
publicly available on this website so
I'm gonna go through this case study
just to give a sense of how one might
think about you know go about training
these kinds of models and then if I have
time I'm gonna do a live demo on a fatal
encounters data set which I thought was
pretty interesting so this is uh that
data set is about fatal police encounter
so people who have died during police
encounter cool so there's one binary
target variable credit risk by the way
if you ever see a label that says good
or bad I would kind of be very skeptical
because it's already hard enough to come
up with labels but when you're encoding
something as good and bad that's like
highly subjective and you know I would
immediately be suspicious of any such
label
they're 28 about 20 input variables
three of which are potential protected
classes I don't think being below 25 is
technically a protected class but for
this example I that's what I chose the
other two are foreign workers and then
female so these I've named these bottom
variables as binary so it's either 0 1 &
1 is the disadvantaged class as I
mentioned earlier okay so the first
thing as I mentioned is there are their
discriminatory discriminatory patterns
in the data
and according to mean difference it
seems like there is so with respect to
women or female protected class your
main difference is 7 percent which is
basically saying that women experience
what's the target variable alright
good credit risk so women are labeled as
bad credit risk at a 7% more a higher
proportion than men and the actually the
effect sizes for the foreign worker and
age below 25 are much higher this is
just I guess the nature of the data set
so next what I did was I trained an
algorithm basic a basic one logistic
regression and I generated predictions
on the test set on this train model so
in orange you'll see this is the raw
data predictions of an orange are the
values you just saw and in blue are the
the values of mean difference learned by
the model so what this is saying is
they're you know in the in case in the
case of female and foreign worker like
the confidence intervals are kind of
they kind of overlap but basically this
is saying that the main kind of point
estimate of the logistic regression
model suggests that it's actually
learned like a learning the
discriminatory discriminatory pattern
and B is larger like the bias is larger
in these models than in the actual data
cool and so finally I wanted to look at
the fairness utility trade-off and and
kind of explain or or make that a little
bit clearer to you so in green I picked
area under the curve as my
classification accuracy metric so that's
like how the utility metric in this case
so how useful is your model and then an
orange is mean difference lower is
better so well closer to zero is better
and with AUC higher is better so as you
can see I've trained five different
models I've trained a baseline which
includes everything so all features
including protected classes and the
second one I removed the protective
attributes from the training data the
third one I relabeled the target target
variables according to that relabeling
technique that I mentioned earlier
fourth one is the additive
counterfactually fare model and then the
fifth one is reject option
classification
and you can see as you kind of use these
messes that I showed you the mean
difference decreases the decrease kind
of is more notable in the cases where
the mean difference was already high in
the first place in the raw data or in
the model the baseline model but the one
thing though a couple things I wanted to
point out here the first one is removing
protected attributes doesn't necessarily
reduce the bias in your in your model
the second thing is that as your model
becomes less and less biased it's
becoming less and less accurate roughly
I mean it's it's not straight you know
linear correlation
I don't think so that that kind of is an
illustration of the fairness utility
trade-off and you know as someone who
works in industry like I'm gonna look at
this plot and I'm gonna say okay so
what's my minimum you know a you sees of
point six are not great so maybe I
wouldn't use these models in the first
place but if I'm you know say this is
larger so this is like maybe it goes
from 90 to like 70 as you use fairness
aware models this is kind of a tool to
think about okay what is the business
you skate like what's the business
requirement here can we make a fair
model that is equally accurate so you
know take the foreign worker case or
even yeah age below 25 and the mean
differences are close to zero but the
accuracy is still pretty much on par
with the baseline model so these are the
kinds of things I would think about and
yeah I guess I'm not allowed to say what
I'm exactly doing it at arena but
I'll just leave it there all right how
much time do we have 15 minutes cool
let's see if we can get this working so
this is a really interesting project I'd
encourage anyone to to look at this but
here's a website basically this
journalist who compiled around 20,000
records going back to 2000 the year 2000
and basically I'm not going to go
through the whole thing because actually
I wasn't able to to complete this
analysis but we have attributes like
subjects name subjects age gender race
and the thing of interest here is this
long one called
official disposition of death justified
or other so this is a label generated by
the police department legal you know I
think the courts a couple of different
places but you're either justified the
the fatality you know was labeled as
justified unreported and then there are
a whole bunch of other ones that maybe I
can look at here yeah so these these are
all of the labels so the majority of
observations are unreported which is sad
times and then the next around at around
for 4,000 of the observations are
labeled as justified and these are just
kind of the top I think 15 of the of the
reasons but basically what I was what
I'm interested in here is can't like
what is what does it mean to train a
model against justified or other
so what I'm gonna skip all of this data
pre-processing stuff I'm gonna stop it
kind of the the exploratory phase of
this but I'm gonna show you this more
interesting one okay so this is race and
this has mean difference just to anchor
ourselves basically one the ye want y
plus is justified so that's like it's
not really a desirable outcome but it's
an outcome that's like okay this the the
person who was killed was a criminal or
you know whatever and then 0 is some
other reason so you know you saw suicide
and that list of things so the
interesting thing here is that so the
the more negative the number is the I
wrote this down
I literally just did this like before
before coming here so yeah so if the
number is negative it means that black
people were labeled justified more often
than not non black people and this is
the only racial category that has this I
mean you know the confidence intervals
on on the rest of them are pretty wide
the point estimate though is positive
and so this I'm not you know we're not
going to make a classifier out of this
in anytime soon but I thought it was an
interesting thing where it's kind of
like you know this isn't these are my
own bias he's coming out but it's kind
of like the court or whoever labeled
this the police officers whoever this is
a story I'm telling myself is that they
they like they more often said that
killing a black person was justified
this is a very stylized interpretation
so you know again take it for a grain of
salt but I was not I honestly was not
expecting this this outcome
I think I'm gonna skip there's another
section about mental illness I think I'm
just gonna jump back to my presentation
cool all right so great we can like
measure stuff and then we can be bias
algorithm so now what I think this thing
we don't want to do is just kind of like
hammer everything down with you know
this hammer and I guess in the next
couple of slides I kind of want to give
a a sketch of like how an FM Li as a
service might work so this is like a use
case so say as a law enforcement agency
I need to identify individuals who are
more likely most likely to be connected
to a gang X for example set aside for
now what you would do with this tool
because I think the tool the the
algorithm itself is like it's an issue
in itself even if you came up with the
fairest algorithm it really depends on
how you use the tool so are you sending
police people like policemen over to you
know police officers over to like black
neighborhoods as a response to this
model you know so so you know I'm gonna
caveat with that basically there are two
stakeholders in the system there are
organizations you know private nonprofit
government they have the data and here
you have a third party predictive
service they have you know the software
in the models and the organization's
will make a contract some kind of
agreement to you know say here's our
data make some models make predictions
for us the first use case of an FM Li is
I'm imagining you know the government
agency that I'm mentioning doesn't
necessarily have like strong tech
infrastructure and you know the most
that they want to do with their data is
I want to measure the degree to which my
data contain discriminatory patterns
so they would use a web service like
this to measure you know feed in the
data you feed in your sensitive
attributes and outcome of interest that
you're trying to predict for so that's
you know that's one idea the other idea
is that this could be used by the
third-party service actually to do all
of these things so this this web service
you know exposes these as part of their
API for example so say you can call API
and say measure and here's your data
payload and then it returned you know
gives you back some kind of response so
the third-party service can use this
FMLA web service to do everything from
measuring discriminatory patterns
fitting models that are fair even
learning fair representation so I'm not
sure if there's too much work on this
but you know idea would be you can train
say a neural net model that has a hidden
layer that has the prejudiced remover
regularizer x' encoded in in the the
activations of those layers and then in
theory I don't know if anyone's done
this but in theory you would learn a
representation of your data that you can
transfer you know to other use cases so
in this case you know the FMLA web
service would return you know feature
fair feature representations or even
models that the third party predictive
service could could use
cool so I'm gonna wrap up pretty soon
but I think these are some pretty cool
future directions in this field there's
a whole laundry list of them so I'll
just briefly kind of touch on each one I
think the first one is important because
I'm not sure if anyone caught this but
basically pretty much all of the
fairness measures that I mentioned
earlier assume that equality is fairness
like fairness is equality and that I
think for many cases that is true but
you know take the case of 9/11 victims a
lot of them suffered chronic illnesses
afterwards and I think this is an actual
case where there is some fund government
fund that had one that needed to
allocate money to victims are you going
to be are you going to allocate the
money equally are you gonna say that
fairness actually in this case is you
know the medical bill like the medical
conditions that were suffering per
family or per individual so this it gets
pretty pretty messy pretty fast you know
if you think of cases a little bit more
nuanced cases where equality is know and
that's not necessarily fair the second
one is multiple sensitive attributes not
much more to say about that except that
it ties in with multi very multi valued
categorical sensitive attributes so this
is taking race and then you know it's
not just black white it's black white
asian latino like what however you want
to discretize it and so i think more
work has to be done in this particular
area because right now most measures are
just they assume binary binary variables
I'm gonna skip most of these I guess you
can chat with me later if you're
interested in any of these an
interesting one actually that I tossed
tossed around in bed at night thinking
about a little bit is this fairness
aware generative modeling so who here
has heard of gams
generative adversarial networks so these
are models that are true they're it's
technically unsupervised but some people
argue there's like a kind of supervised
task component to it but basically
you're showing real images and totally
gonna butcher this but basically the
model learns how to generate realistic
images based on what the images you show
it so if you show it a bunch of faces
it'll learn how to generate faces in a
nutshell so this is interesting because
if you're trying to come up with a
facial you know recognition software you
could go about it by collecting a lot of
training data of all races so like
including all you know the diversity of
all our beautiful face shapes and the
model is going to learn about that and
if you're trying to if you're trying to
train a supervised model that recognizes
faces maybe if you haven't shown it any
faces of you know Southeast Asian person
then it's not going to recognize my face
and then my iPhone will unlock and
things like that obviously this doesn't
happen but it'd be interesting to look
into ways of creating a generative model
that has a notion of like even if it
hasn't been shown Southeast Asian faces
somehow you can modify the somehow you
can learn a model that is still able to
learn those by kind of synthesizing data
and kind of augmenting your data set by
kind of manipulating face
anyway I'm gonna I'm rambling I'm gonna
close with this so to me the most
interesting part of this area is you're
basically trying to this is basically
the task you're trying to take ethics
and values try to turn it to math and
then you're trying to turn those
mathematical formulations into like a
model that exists in the real world and
I think this exercise is really
interesting to me there are there are a
lot of areas you know disciplines
sectors of society that within which
like this process of translating ethics
into math is really like we need all
these things to to figure it out and
what I mentioned today is kind of just
scratching the surface and as a very
kind of simplified toy environment with
which we can start kind of thinking
about these issues
sorry I lied this is what I'll end with
so if you're a data scientist or a
statistician or if you're going into
into this this area at all
these are some of the questions that I
think are super important to ask in
one's analysis and model building
process so you can read them but I think
this one is really important it's like
who labeled my data in the first place
or like what process generated these
labels because again these algorithms
are excellent at like optimizing and
finding the this the place and model
space that predicts very well given that
those are the labels that you really
want so I don't really have any
prescriptions unlike how to solve this
problem if you determine that your label
data is actually incorrect but I think
that's something we need to be cognizant
of and then finally I think the other
the last one I want to emphasize is the
second to last one so what what do my
predictions mean and how can how can
they be misinterpreted or misused by the
end-user so you know take take the
higher not higher recommendation like if
the model outputs 0.5 to like what does
that mean I mean was is the person
likely to be hired like if you have a
point 5 threshold you know that that
label will be one so this kind of puts
emphasis on product people not only data
scientists to figure out what kind of
user interface how do you communicate to
a user who doesn't know anything about
machine learning what this prediction
that they're looking at you know
and how they should use it and will that
I'll end thanks so much for coming in
this this really cold day you can reach
me at Twitter I'm really not on it that
often but if you have any more questions
you can can ping me on there Thanks Oh
[Applause]
questions yeah
and then because what happens
if I am if I'm understanding the
question correctly so so in the example
you mentioned with zip code I'm assuming
Europe one hot encoding the zip code
values so you have say you have like 100
unique zip codes and you 1 how to encode
them so that it's like basically dummy
variables I don't know how well this
model will deal with that I feel like it
might but I haven't really looked at
that yeah but what I will say about that
is that I think this this is like the
strongest this is the type of
counterfactually fare model this was
like a paper written I think this year
is in the class of counterfactually fare
models that makes a strongest assumption
that the relationships are linear they
do have some techniques that allow for
nonlinear relationships I don't know
yeah I'd have to dig into the literature
to to wrap my head around that but
hopefully that didn't answer your
question
yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah come talk to me talk
to me out there though yeah yeah
Hey
how
yeah
yeah yeah totally feel like there were
two questions there I guess the first
one is yeah there are even even outside
of the fairness aware literature like
one can use stratified metrics so you
can measure AUC stratified by some
categorical variable so that kind of
gets at how well your model is
performing like by group but to go back
to your first question about like other
ways of measuring fairness one would
have to make a couple more assumptions
so so let me step back there is I'm kind
of piggybacking on like legal concepts
but in terms of fairness there's you
know procedural justice and then there's
a procedural fairness and then there's
you know distributive fairness and under
distributive fairness there's equality
so give equal amounts of money to all
all 911 victims and there's the
proportionality definition which is you
have to introduce another assumption
that says what how which group like how
do you define need with respect to some
with respect to the individuals in your
data set so you know in the 911 example
it's like need might be operationalized
by as i mentioned like how many people
are in the family or what kinds of men
medical conditions and how much those
costs to treat or you know maintain
so I'll give you a non-answer in that
I'm not sure how but a step in the right
direction would be to somehow encode a
notion of proportionality
sorry that was not a great answer
yeah thank you for that huh
yeah yeah totally I I would say that
there are very few there are there are a
few data contexts in which this kind of
binary system would work well and the
closer to you get the closer you get to
actual kind of like laws like
anti-discrimination laws like you can't
hire based on such and such attributes
those cases are fairly clear-cut
although they can also be really complex
how
not great hey I don't know what so what
exactly is is a question
because grease fire
yeah yeah I mean that gets at the
question of confounders so we use you
know we we have proxies like we make
decisions based on kind of heuristics as
people I guess my response to that would
be to get that data but yeah I don't
really have a straightforward answer to
that that's why I kind of technically
it's it's potential discrimination
because it's it's a bias towards one
group the favoring one group or you know
and it's not it's not like a final say
and it's not like a concrete kind of
assert assertion about the model
yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
Oh
yeah none of the techniques I showed
really get at that question that's a
much tougher question to get up what it
could say is like hey you've specified
these protected classes here are some
other variables that you wouldn't have
suspected to be correlated with it that
in fact are so it would be able to tell
you that much and it would be able to
say by what confidence interval like the
relationship is like it'll give you a
point estimate of the magnitude and also
like confidence about you know how how
correlated does those intuitively
non-sensitive features are actually
correlated with your sensitive classes
but in terms of like a thing that says
oh your data is bad don't use it or try
to change it around a little bit yeah I
don't think that's an easy issue to
solve
all the rooms
it's still a little unclear to me but
yeah we can we can chat later yeah
yeah totally I mean this is a very large
issue of trust adoption so so the second
thing you mentioned of tracking I think
that's important I think like we tracked
the performance of our models just even
outside of the fairness contact so I
think it makes sense to if if the
company cares about this and again
there's there's really no way for like
me to convince predictive analytics
company to be say like okay implement
this stuff now because it's likely a
start-up which is kind of where I'm
working I'm kind of doing this work sort
of on the side and trying to try to
influence you know people in my company
in this in this direction so yeah for
your second point I think like measuring
is always I think a good thing even
though your instrument might be
imperfect to your first question I think
it depends on the use case of the
company using this kind of software
personally I think it should these kinds
of models should influence the decision
maker because my my opinion and this is
just an opinion is that and this is well
documented where recruiters will hire
people more like them or you know
they'll you'll you'll learn patterns of
you know I've been recruiting for 20
years and you you know X Y & Z are the
features that I look at when making a
hire decision and maybe X is actually a
true connection and y&z are just kind of
proxies or correlates to a good
performer so yeah I think I think these
kinds of predictive algorithms should be
inserted you know into like kind of a
human in the loop process where these
kinds of models actually kind of
influence the decision
made by by in this case recruiters
yeah I mean one something that one could
do is train a model that model generates
a prediction and you can do something
like keep all the inputs the same but
make this person like like black how
does that change the prediction if that
changes the prediction if it actually
flips the prediction just changing that
one value in the input then that's cause
of for suspicion in in the model so that
that's kind of I don't know so just to
be clear this is kind of a solution in
search of problems that we know you know
our problems at the high level but when
it gets when when we start kind of
specifying that in terms of like actual
real-world problems it it becomes very
hard to to see where these solutions fit
in besides like this is the typical
measure study kind of thing
I
here
sorry I didn't really I didn't didn't
quite catch that
yeah yeah I missed some keywords
we decided that
yeah that's I mean that's interesting
it's I don't know I feel like the
algorithmic related legislation in this
country like I'm not really an expert in
this but my feeling is that it's not
really well developed like I don't I
think it would be a great thing for some
kind of oversight of these kinds of
algorithms I do know there's a
congressman in New York that's trying to
pass a bill that says a government
agency who uses third-party predictive
software has to make the data
transparent and then also publish the
source code of anything that made it so
I don't know if that's what you're
trying to get at but yeah I I don't have
much of a relevant reaction sorry yeah
yeah yeah this is why I like this topic
it's not it's not just like oh yeah you
know technical stuff
thank you
no yeah so you're saying that when
you're training the k-nearest neighbors
model it should actually creep it should
actually partition those those
observations such that there is no
difference between neighbors ish yeah
that's that's an interesting question I
I haven't really thought about that too
much
but yeah that's an interesting thought
yeah yeah I think one can think of many
cases where these kinds of models well
work as intended or the point of them is
to be biased in a sense so I mean the
the gang-member example I'd have to
think about that a little bit more but
to your first point you're talking about
the regularization right so if it's zero
then that term drops out and then if
it's greater than one then you start
carrying I think it says abstract and
meaningless as the other regularization
term so it's so like with l2
regularization a value of a hundred is
just doesn't really mean anything really
other than you're just saying penalize
you know high weights in your model so
in the same way I think with the
prejudice regularization a value greater
than one it really just depends on the
data like what that particular value
does in the model how that particular
value changes your your model space
all right so one more and we're off
thank you
[Applause]